paris à deux pas des champs elysées
nous sommes dans l'un des spas les plus
prestigieux du monde ici dans la plus
grande discrétion star et hommes
d'affaires viennent s'offrir un moment
de calme de luxe et de volupté pour
répondre aux exigences de sa clientèle
isabelle la responsable des massages
utilise depuis peu un produit que l'on
dit exceptionnel une huile magique
nous en tant que toute une gamme de
massage dans lé en particulier et à
l'huile d'argan l'huile d'argan c'est la
nouvelle star des spas les masseurs ne
jurent que par elle et les clients
réservent des semaines à l'avancé leurs
séances de massage 150 euros pour une
heure de détente à l'huile d'argan
c'est le prix à payer pour profiter des
bienfaits de cette huile que l'on nous
vend comme le nouveau produit miracle je
fume nous qui allons pouvoir
exceptionnel au niveau la régénération
de la peau qui a aussi beaucoup
d'antioxydants donkey cas un facteur
envier aux petits vieillissement et puis
c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté très
nourrissants pour l'impôt nos clients
ont envie de découvrir des choses
exceptionnelles précieux rare donc ça
vexe avant tout à fait dans ce cadre là
mais l'huile d'argan n'est pas seulement
l'huile de massage à la mode
avec sa saveur de noisette grillée c'est
la nouvelle coqueluche des grands chefs
un produit gastronomique à 140 euros le
litre dans certaines épiceries fines
je ne connaissais pas
[Musique]
c'est aussi un produit de beauté qui
séduit les plus grandes marques de
cosmétiques dans les supermarchés gel
douche shampoing baume à l'huile d'argan
envahissent les rayons
[Musique]
pourtant l'huile d'argan est un produit
artisanal rares fabriqué uniquement
maroc par les villageoises berbère
comment ce produit méconnu est il devenu
en cinq ans l'huile la plus chère du
monde
à qui profite ce succès nous avons aussi
découvert de petites et de grosses
arnaques enquête sur l'huile d'argan
l'or vert du désert
[Applaudissements]
tout commence ici au sud ouest du maroc
dans cette région poussent un arbre
surprenant que les touristes appel
l'arbre à chèvres les biquettes grains
dans les branches pour en déguster les
fruits
j'ai jamais vu ça se voit moins drôle
cet arbre c'est la regagner
l'emblème du maroc une espèce très rare
vieille de plusieurs millions d'années
et qui ne pousse qu'ici nous sommes aiba
au coeur des montagnes de l'atlas
depuis toujours les jeunes filles
berbère récolte les fruits de l'arganier
à la main pour les apporter à leur mère
ce matin saina doit préparer un litre
d'huile d'argan pour son foyer
c'est comme ça tous les jours les femmes
s'en servent pour la cuisine mais aussi
pour protéger leur peau du soleil
première étape elle doit concassé entre
deux pierres lannoy très dur de
l'arganier pour en extraire des amendes
[Musique]
puis elle fait griller les amandes au
feu de bois avant de les presser pendant
des heures dans un moulin pour obtenir
la pâte d'argan
un travail laborieux
faire un litre d'huile ça me prend toute
la matinée
c'est très fatigant quand vous presser
de l'huile d'argan vous ne pouvez rien
faire d'autre de la journée tellement
vous êtes fatigué pour obtenir l'huile
zaïna doit rajouter à la pâte d'argan
une quantité d'eau bien précises un
savoir faire ancestral transmis de
génération en génération
mais considérez vous plaisir est ce
qu'il ya des hommes qui fabriquent de
l'huile d'argan
non c'est le travail des femmes et des
filles elles doivent apprendre dès le
plus jeune âge
moi même j'ai initié méfie il aura fallu
six heures de travail et les fruits
d'une dizaine d'arbres pour produire ce
litre d'huile d'argan
[Musique]
on
un liquide sacré chez les berbères zaïna
et ses voisines en mange tous les jours
à l'heure du thé nous on fait une pâte à
l'huile d'argan que l'on donne à manger
aux bébés quand les bébés prensa ils
sont très robustes
avant il n'y avait même pas de l'air on
ne donnait que ça aux nourrissons c'est
des gens qui ont été levés avec l'huile
d'argan à l'antenne vieillissent ils
n'ont aucune ride a faim parce qu'il
s'en remette sur le visage et sur les
mains les vertus magiques de l'huile
d'argan
il n'y a pas que les femmes berbères qui
s'y intéressent notre enquête nous
conduit à 800 km de là un rabat la
capitale du maroc
[Musique]
zoubida charrouf et chercheuse à la
faculté des sciences spécialiste des
plantes médicinales
depuis dix ans dans son laboratoire elle
mène de nombreuses recherches sur
l'huile d'argan elle a étudié ses effets
sur les maladies cardiovasculaires et
sur le vieillissement de la peau ces
nuits les quais des propriétés
antioxydantes pour ça qu elle prévient
les reee pour prévenir les maladies
cardiovasculaires
il est recommandé de prendre
une cuillérée à soupe par jour moi-même
j'utilise de l'huile d'argan tous les
jours et c'est vrai que j'avais un taux
de cholestérol de 2,6 et actuellement je
suis à 2,1
mais il faut beaucoup de temps pour que
saab est ce vraiment le taux de
cholestérol
l'huile d'argan at elle vraiment des
vertus médicinales
nous sommes allés poser la question à
l'agencé française de sécurité
alimentaire
pour la nutritionniste en chef l'argent
n'est pas un médicament
si l'huile d'argan comme l'huile de
colza peut atténuer le cholestérol ses
propriétés ne sont pas efficaces pour
toutes les populations d'argan présente
pas forcément des qualités qui vont
permettre de rééquilibrer les apports
alimentaires en certains acides gras qui
sont déjà déséquilibré chez nous alors
ce qui ce qui est peut-être vrai au
maroc dans un contexte alimentaire
données peut ne pas l'être chez nous
parce que nos habitudes alimentaires
sont différentes et nos habitudes de vie
seront différents les travaux de zoubida
charrouf sont malgré tout prometteur
persuadé du potentiel commercial de ces
tuiles elle part à la recherche de
subventions pour créer une coopérative
qui sera géré par les femmes berbères
elle-même du commerce équitable
il lui aura fallu dix ans pour réussir
son pari elle nous emmène dans un
village reculé
visiter l'une des coopératives qu'elle a
lancé aujourd'hui elle ne s'en occupe
plus les 34 femmes de la coopérative
sont totalement autonome
[Applaudissements]
ici toutes les femmes sont actionnaires
de la coopérative
elles se partagent les bénéfices en
fonction du volume de fruits concassé un
revenu minimum de 5 euros par jour leur
est garanti c'est deux fois plus que ce
qu'elle gagnait avant la coopérative on
devait toujours compter sur notre mari
ou le fils pour faire vivre la famille
aujourd'hui on peut compter sur nous
mêmes on ne dépend plus des sommes pour
acheter ce qui nous plaît maintenant on
est un vrai couple on s'entraide mon
mari et moi on est comme égaux moi je
viens la coopérative pour gagner un peu
d'argent je peux acheter un peu de
viande est allé au hammam mais
construire une maison avec sa non ce
n'est pas possible
deux fois par semaine la salle de
travail de la coopérative se transforme
en salle de classe
nous allons reprendre à la page 22 nous
reprenons la dernière leçon
ces femmes qui ne sont jamais allés à
l'école peuvent enfin apprendre à lire
et à écrire
l'entrejeu langues 95% des trains avait
donc je trouve c'est un homme comme quoi
c'est pas ma été marginalisés pourquoi
ils n'ont pas une reconnaissance et je
suis très confiant face à leur travail
ils ont limité aussi c'est très
important je le ressens encore que fin
mai je suis très facile à zoug ida
charrouf a même réussi à trouver des
mécènes pour acheter aux femmes des
presses mécanique meilleure hygiène
meilleur rendement avec ses machines la
coopérative peut produire jusqu'à 4000
litres d'huile d'argan par an pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 80 mille euros
sa couleur dorée on dirait vraiment que
c'est l'or à l'élaboration de produits
et les produits cosmétiques les crèmes
des shampoings gels douche lait
tous les
les huiles de massage zoubida charrouf a
lancé six autres coopératif qui se sont
regroupées pour répondre à la demande de
plus en plus forte de l'étranger elle
exporte en france mais aussi au canada
au japon
un succès inespéré pour les femmes du
village
le lendemain matin un français vient
prendre livraison d'une commande
importante c'est le plus gros client de
la coopérative
bonjour comment ça va pas michel sauvade
crois beaucoup aux vertus de l'huile
d'argan comment ça va bien
son meilleur argument commercial s'est
lui même
je viens pour la signature du contrat
moi personnellement je m'en mets tous
les matins et c'est vrai que ça marche
bien
j'étais presque chaud je mets du squat
des chevaux et ça va mieux aussi
ah si si si je peux vous le montrer j'ai
des photos de moi donc il ya dix ans
j'avais moins de cheveux que maintenant
il s'agit de garantir pourtant sur la
photo la différence n'est pas flagrante
michel sow basa surtout de l'ambition
pour cette coopérative
il veut faire de 100 d'huile un produit
de luxe il a créé une ligne de
cosmétiques haut de gamme qu'il espère
vendre dans les salons de massage les
plus renommés comme celui ci situé dans
l'un des plus beaux palaces de paris
michel sauvade a envoyé son fils
présenter les échantillons de son huile
d'exception à la directrice du spa
l'enjeu est énorme
c'est le premier palace qui a accepté de
le recevoir
ce produit est le plus concentré le plus
riche est sans doute parmi les plus
efficaces au monde
c'est un cocktail vraiment mais vraiment
exceptionnel on a une grosse
concentration les narguant et on a les
deux premiers actifs objective et au
monde anti vergetures pour vaincre la
directrice il n'hésite pas à se servir
de l'image d'une célèbre chanteuse
australienne
ca c sérums on l'a donnée à kylie
minogue ce qui a vraiment adoré nous a
donné l'autorisation formelle de dire
qu'elle avait vraiment aimé life y en a
tellement aimé qu'elle a demandé à avoir
la gamme quoi donc ça c'était vraiment
ça fait super plaisir
ces produits qui s est vraiment là tous
touchés parce qu'elle leur en fait la
gang a toujours une touche et qui est
beaucoup plus on les sent déjà que c'est
nourrissant
mission accomplie la directrice du spa
est séduite l'huile des femmes berbères
parvient à conquérir les palaces les
plus luxueux retour au maroc direction
agadir cité balnéaire qui attire des
millions de vacanciers
ici à chaque coin de rue on trouve des
boutiques spécialisées dans le commerce
de ce nouvel or jaune ce magasin
accueille plus de 300 touristes par jour
français anglais allemand un supermarché
où l'on trouve des centaines de produits
à l'huile d'argan
ici on vous promet bien des miracles
contre l'eczéma le cholestérol
la cellulite et même le psoriasis
le psoriasis et un résultat psychique du
de stress ou alors souvent ça vient ça
part mais suffit juste d'appliquer
quelques couches en coton combler les
petits problèmes de pousser du psoriasis
oui normalement donc j'espère que ça va
s'engager en achetant dans cette
boutique
les touristes sont aussi persuader de
venir en aide aux femmes démunies
c'est ce que leur vend habilement un
discours commercial bien rodé on a
commencé à taroudant avec des femmes
jusqu'à présent on a cette femme là une
petite coopérative de nous petite
production de nous et surtout les femmes
qui sont dans les parties rural alors
c'est très bien pour s'amuser ils seront
ils sont des femmes veuves aux biens des
femmes qui ont aucune vie dans des
déficits condition séduite par les
arguments de la vendeuse cette cliente
française va acheter pour plus de 160
euros de produits sur les cadeaux durant
les dames de la main même de lui en
insistant auprès de la commerçante
nous découvrons pourtant que ce magasin
n'a rien de vraiment équitable est une
société privée
cette société privée mais elle s'était
qu'il ya beaucoup de
l'espace beaucoup de femmes notre maison
que ce tour la vendeuse s'empêtre dans
ses explications mais nous sommes bien
dans une société privée pas de
villageoises actionnaires ici les
bénéfices des ventes vont dans la poche
d'un seul patron qui n'a pas souhaité
nous rencontrer pour profiter du nouveau
filon tous les mois se crée une nouvelle
coopérative du d'armand sur la route
entre agadir et marrakech
on en compte une centaine qui font
travailler plus de 2000 femmes
notre enquête se poursuit à 20 km au
nord d'essaouira
dans cet établissement situé au bord
d'une route très touristique
bizarrement les femmes se remettent au
travail lorsque nous arrivons
pourtant celle qui se présente comme la
présidente nous assure qu'il s'agit bien
d'une vraie coopérative agréé par l'état
c'était une coopérative c'est ça le but
c'est parce que c'est l'heure
c'est pas un travail chez quelqu'un
elles dépendent de leur propre économie
d'elle-même qu'on vient de gagner à peu
près par jour pour sa journée à 28 euros
la journée pour la journée parce qu'elle
a beaucoup travaillé des salaires
surprenant c'est six fois plus que dans
toutes les autres coopératives
lorsqu'on demande le volume de
production le chiffre nous semble
irréaliste pour une huile pressés à la
main en fait on produit tous les enfants
moins de 10 minutes
tous les ans c'est destiné par l'échelle
internationale et l'échelle nationale
oui
ce discours nous laisse sceptique nous
décidons de vérifier ces informations
en appelant un haut fonctionnaire du
ministère de l'agriculture du maroc qui
enquête sur cette coopérative et
souhaite rester anonyme
elles me disent les femmes étaient
rémunérés 28 euros par jour 28 euros par
jour ils me disent aussi qu'ils
produisaient dix mille litres par an oui
alors pourquoi est ce qu'ils nous disent
ça d'après vous encore appelée à gérer
donc c'est à dire que les bénéfices ne
serait pas reverser sa une entreprise
privée l'agrément du ministère permet
d'obtenir des aides financières
c'est donc pour obtenir frauduleusement
ces subventions que certaines sociétés
privées se font passer pour des
coopératives à marrakech
nous avons découvert une escroquerie
d'une autre ampleur
dans le souk très touristique de la
ville on trouve de l'huile d'argan dans
toutes les échoppes
dans cette boutique qui s'affiche comme
une herboristerie nous sommes accueillis
par un homme en blouse blanche aux
allures de pharmaciens c'est la coiffure
et les matins voulez-vous n'est pas même
qui est convenu et vue de séduire la
santé il n'y a pas mieux que ça le matin
m
pour le cholestérol pour les maux de
coeur pour les articulations pour
empocher les articulations
alors comme ça tout ça chacun 150 une
telle 150 la troisième gratuite mais
j'ai trouvé une analyse et
internationalement kolo touré 100%
d'accord
nous prenons le pharmacien au mot et
allons faire analyser son nuit là nous
achetons pour 15 euros un flacon de 60
millilitres que nous confions aux
laboratoires de zoubida charrouf la
chercheuse de l'université de rabat
après des recherches poussées
le résultat est sans appel c'est une
huile d'argan falsifié sa composition
100 % tournesol 0% arguant à 15 euros le
flacon une belle arnaque l'huile de
tournesol coûte dix fois moins cher que
larguant depuis peu les coopératives
marocaines font face à une nouvelle
concurrence
les grands groupes cosmétiques
internationaux achètent des dizaines de
milliers de litres d'argan la demande
explose alors sur le marché les prix
flambent
le souk de tam l'est au nord d'essaouira
la marchandise que tout le monde
s'arrache c'est l'abandon qui permet de
produire l'huile d'argan les familles
des alentours qui ont tout casser les
noix chez elle vient de vendre leurs
productions les plus gros acheteurs sont
les français il domine la filière benoît
robin est le premier producteur d'huile
d'argan au monde
ce matin il vient contrôler auprès
d'omar son intermédiaire les achats de
la journée
salam aleikoum le travail de mars c'est
d'avoir tous les jours entre deux et
trois tonnes d'amandes ont d'excellentes
qualités et lui elle l était il était la
balance il vérifie à chaque fois les
quantités donc celle à d'anciennes
balance avec les pois on prétend tara
falloir donc l'argent passe ma ville
demain il faut être prêt il faut des
petites coupures et pour aller très très
vite
voilà on espère c'est un bon souffle tel
messe aujourd'hui on espère acheter
peut-être maximum trois tonnes et pour
acheter des abandons en si grande
quantité il faut dépenser beaucoup
d'argent dans sa sacoche
omar d'intermédiaire à plus de 10000
euros
[Musique]
la la la la la
et cela ça me manque justement les
prononce pas la regarde ça c'est
vraiment de l'amandon nickel pour
répondre aux exigences des grands
laboratoires cosmétiques l'amandon doit
être d'une qualité irréprochable
il est large il est blanc il est tout de
suite très gras c'est la première chose
déterminante pour nous excellent acteur
en une matinée il a acheté pour 7500
euros d'amendé
direction le centre de triage
dans ce local
une cinquantaine de femmes travaillent
pour benoît robin toute la journée elles
doivent trier les amendes en acheter au
souk avant qu'il ne parte en usine pour
être pressé aujourd'hui simplement ses
morceaux des corses ne peuvent pas
entrer dans la machine
la directrice de l'usiné nous dit que
les femmes gagnent le même salaire que
dans une coopérative 4 euros par jour
nous demandons à une des travailleuses
combien y gagne et c'est la directrice
qui nous sert d'interprète
els van 40 grammes par jour et c'est
juste juste de retour à paris nous avons
fait traduire l'interview
et là surprise ce n'est plus du tout la
même version
combien tu gagnes ici ici oui je dois
dire la vérité
oui je gagne 50 dirhams pour deux jours
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour toi non
c'est vraiment et je suis là tous les
jours je m'absente jamais la directrice
a exagéré elle a multiplié par deux le
salaire de cette femme
dans cette usine ultramoderne chaque
mois benoît robin presse 30 tonnes
d'amandes on qui produisent plus de
quinze mille litres d'huile d'argan
ça c'est de l'huile brute il faut savoir
que c'est lui la plus chère du monde
et comme c'est lui la plus chère du
monde on ne peut pas se permettre de
perdre ne serait-ce qu'un demi-litre il
ya ce qu'il faut il nous en reste pour
benoît robin van son huile par bidon de
200 litres ou plus grandes marques de
cosmétiques mais secret industriel
oblige il n'a pas le droit de donner
leur nom enfin probablement refaire pour
les chinois pour la commande chinoise
s'en faut regarder ça les femmes gagnent
5 euros par jour entre 4 et 5 euros par
jour nous on gagne 1000 euros par fut et
un labo peut gagner entre trente et
cinquante mille euros par avec les
produits finis et le gros paradoxe de
notre métier c'est plus client est gros
moins il fait de commerce équitable en
france le marché est en plein essor
shampoings gels douche crème à l'huile
d'argan envahissent nos magasins aucune
marque ne veut passer à côté de ce
nouveau produit phare
[Musique]
sur les étiquettes l'huile d'argan du
maroc est le premier argument de vente
mais quelle en est la teneur réelle
nous choisissons cinq produits au hasard
dans un supermarché pour les faire
analyser par un laboratoire indépendant
le résultat est pour le moins surprenant
- 2 2 % d'huile d'argan pour le gel
douche -2 2% pour l'huile pour les
cheveux même résultat pour le savon le
shampoing et la crème pour les mains
nous montrons les résultats un expert
l'huile d'argan est elle vraiment
efficace s'il y en a moins de 2% dans un
produit l'huile d'argan pur moi je suis
d'accord parce que c'est une huile
hydratante antioxydantes etc
mais je pense pas que juste 2 % dans une
crème hydratante soit suffisant pour
garder les propriétés réelles de l'huile
d'argan pur pour moi je pense que c'est
un argument marketing
nous avons contacté les grands groupes
cosmétiques qui fabrique ces cinq
produits tous garantissent l'efficacité
de leurs crèmes ou leur shampoing et
précisent que leur qualité est le
résultat d'une formule composée de
nombreux ingrédients dont l'huile
d'argan malgré tout l'huile d'argan est
un formidable atout économique pour le
maroc mais un atout fragile l'arganier
est un arbre menacé chaque année 600
hectares disparaissent à cause de la
sécheresse et des cultures maraîchères
poursuvi d'achat ruf
c'est un enjeu écologique majeure largan
est en train de disparaître regarder
dans toutes ces terrains y avait encore
un ici et là bas et c'est tout les gens
l'ont l'enlever et l'ont remplacé par
d'autres cultures qui rapporte
certainement plus d'argent que
l'arganier mais qui nécessite beaucoup
d'eau des cultures qui sont pas adaptés
à ses soldats à ce climat est la
conséquence est ce qu'on est en train de
voir s'est lamenté du désert cc
l'arganeraie qui va disparaître c'est
l'exode rural vers les villes
marocaines vers l'europe de toute la
population sait c'est vraiment le désert
le vrai sens du terme
[Musique]
l'arganier a été classée patrimoine
universel par l'unesco et l'union
européenne vient de financer la
plantation de quarante mille arbres mais
cette espèce qui ne pousse qu'au maroc
est capricieuse il va falloir attendre
dix ans avant que ces nouveaux plans ne
donne des fruits
personne ne sait s'il produiront une
huile de bonne qualité si la source
venait à se tarir
le miracle de l'argan ne serait alors
qu'un mirage
[Musique]